[Music]
this guy is
so I I had uh I wanted to bring
something to your attention
um yeah
uh about about like when it comes to the
crucifixion a big thing for me is I I
shared with you last time was about I
believe that this what happened to Jesus
was prophesied 700 years before he was
it even happened to him now and a
thousand years before it was even a few
hundred years before it was even
invented like crucifixion yeah um I
wanted to show you so have you ever read
Isaiah 53
uh no I actually haven't I mean I heard
Muslims call Isaiah 42 for like you know
the prophet Muhammad uh uh being a
prophet uh yeah I never read the whole
chapter of Isaiah they're not if you
wanted to bring something I'd be
interested bro yeah okay for sure I
wanted okay let me show you this really
quick and I want just get your thoughts
so here it is bro
um
okay
so this is what it says so
it's only 12 verses we'll look at a few
we're gonna look at all of it just a few
key ones but
he says who has believed what he has
heard from us is prophet Isaiah who is
he what he has heard from us and to whom
has the arm of the Lord been revealed
for he grew up before him like a young
plant and like a root out of dry ground
he had no form or Majesty
that we should look at him and no beauty
that we should desire him
he was despised and rejected by men
a Man of Sorrows and acquainted with
grief
and as one whom men hide their faces he
was despised and we esteemed him not
but surely he has borne our griefs and
carried our sorrows
yet we esteemed him stricken Smitten by
God and afflicted
but he was pierced for our
transgressions and he was crushed for
our iniquities upon him was the
chastisement that brought us peace
and with his wounds we are healed
so notice how it talks about how this
person
he bore our grease he carried our
sorrows right yet we thought that he was
being punished by God
but he was pierced for our
transgressions he was crushed for our
iniquities our sins
and upon him was the chastisement the
punishment that brought us peace and
with his wounds we're healed
all we like sheep have gone astray we
have turned everyone to his own way
and the lord has laid on him the
iniquity of us all
right so God put our sins on him yeah so
just reading this so far
top of the head if you were to just
you're just reading this no biases or
nothing who does this sound like to you
well this one this sounds like uh Jesus
Christ from the biblical narrative that
he's going to come and be like the
sacrificial peace like for Humanity his
his wounds will heal our heal us etc etc
so so this is what we um stuff like this
man that we have like literally the
story of the biblical Jesus that we find
in the gospel narratives in something
that pre-existed Jesus before he was
born
so for me this is something that is like
yeah God spoke and he said it will
happen and it happened
um on top of the historical evidence
that you know we can go through but just
if we talk in scripture the scripture
says that it will happen and it
describes what happened to Jesus exactly
how we see or have heard about Jesus for
Generations you know so what are your
thoughts on that yeah can we can we uh
run it back from the top one time we
could just uh I know you like read it
slow so I could like it could like
marinate but uh could we just reorient
this uh who has believed what he has
heard from us and to whom has the arm of
the Lord been revealed for he grew up
before him like a young plant hey this
is fire bro hey
us
and to whom has the arm of the Lord be
revealed for he grew up before him like
a young plant and like a root out of a
dry ground he had no form or Majesty
that we should look at him and no beauty
that we should desire him he was
despised and rejected by Men A Man of
Sorrows and acquainted with grief
and as from whom men hide their faces he
was despised and we esteemed him not
surely he has borne our griefs and
carried our sorrows yet we esteemed them
stricken Smitten by God and Afflicted
but he was pierced for our
transgressions he was crushed for our
iniquities upon him was the chastisement
that brought us peace and with his
wounds we are healed all we like sheep
have to go on the street we have turned
everyone to we have turned everyone to
his own way and the lord has laid on him
the iniquity of all of us all he was a
press does it go on further oh yeah it
goes on but that's where we we stopped
at six we can go on a little bit late I
just wanted to get your general thought
yeah bro that's that's actually hard bro
like I was gonna cry no like actually
like well that's crazy bro
no that that's fire I should like I
actually like like the the way it's
weird so I feel like I was reading like
some like yeah that's crazy no what's it
called uh yeah I mean I I would I would
uh say that that's that's actually um
like when you see like these verses
inside the Old Testament and you compare
it to the New Testament the biblical
narrative like uh it does it does meet
each other but I wouldn't pose a
question right because in the same way
like Muslims use uh you know like
certain verses of like the the Bible Etc
um
like for example Isaiah 42 like what do
you make of like the Muslim perspective
on that and the way that the Muslims uh
uh I don't know bro it bro like okay
okay I'ma just say it bro sometimes I
see Muslims I see Christians and I see
Jews bending scripture to fit their
narratives I see it sometimes now I'm
not saying that you're a victim of this
here I mean this this seems like uh like
it's like it's speaking about like
obviously Jesus Christ
um but I mean but again a skeptic could
say like oh I could have been speaking
about somebody else this is that in the
third but like at the same time Muslims
can look to the Bible and then look at
verses and then make it to theirs as
well you feel me like what do you make
up Isaiah 42 like could you could you go
to that and then read it and then yeah
we can go to it so and we'll compare
we'll compare the method here so notice
how
notice how when we when we read this
there was no narrative that we put on
this but we we just read it line by line
word for word right and automatically we
we're like yeah this is talking about
Jesus for sure like this is what we find
in the biblical Narrative of Jesus hands
down no bias is needed no none of that
right so now let's go to Isaiah 42 and
let's see if it's if it's clear like
that that we get oh yeah this is
Muhammad you know what I'm saying this
is Muhammad
look at it
[Music]